[Applause]
it's sexy morphin time
yeah okay that wasn't a thing until now
because kylie jenner just dressed up as
one seriously hot
mighty morphin power ranger i love it
and we'll never look at our favorite
childhood show the same way again
tyrannosaurus on thursday the 23 year
old showed off her
red hot superhero halloween getup on
instagram
yep that's the kylie cosmetics founder
rocking a red wig
a crop top with a white belt
high-waisted red leggings
and white-heeled boots of course her
squad was on hand to complete the crew
that's stassi as the pink ranger
victoria as the blue one
sofia as the yellow ranger and carter in
black
kylie shared this clip with her friends
on instagram
alongside the caption go go power
rangers
all right guys can you guess who i am
for halloween this year of course you
can
[Music]
so let's go find them tigers
i'm right here all my kids are the
tigers son
kylie's big sis kim kardashian also hit
up instagram to show off her halloween
costume
and if you didn't get it by now here's a
hint
hey all you cool cats and kittens yeah
she dressed up as tiger king's carol
baskin
carol baskin
i don't know the rest carol baskin
killed her husband
kim and kanye west's kiddos north saint
shy and
psalm were all tiny tigers
guys what's up where's the tigers at and
kim's bestie jonathan chebin
was one convincing joe exotic
oh hey carol i didn't even know you were
here i mean
the resemblance is uncanny
naturally they documented the whole
thing with an epic photo shoot
go stand right by jonathan and and
scream to me one on either side of
jonathan
look at the camera great the two even
made a few references to allegations
that carol
who recently appeared on this season of
dancing with the stars
killed her late husband don lewis a
claim she has vehemently denied
joe come here guys look
the whole family's here except your
husband cameron
back in march when literally everyone in
their mother was binge watching tiger
king
kim tweeted asking fans if they thought
carol had
in fact been responsible for her
husband's death
at the time carol's current husband
howard baskin
posted a video addressing kim directly
i doubt if kim will see this video but
if she were to come
and spend an hour with carol i know she
would have her answer and i know
what it would be and of course we would
welcome her visiting if she wanted to